Look,
I used to play quake competitively and if you tell people how quick teams are
that their clans,
the Queensland people,
like what?
And then they were like,
you mean like the KKK?
You're like,
no,
just a group of people like quake.
You fucking idiot with a common mentality.
That's it.
Oh,
a group.
A band of people banned.
Yeah,
brothers.
That happens.
People just take over something and then that's something becomes negative from
then on.
Well then they have a platform as well,
you know that they can then they're like social social justice warriors about
it.
You know,
they're like chairing it from the rooftops and making tweets about it and how,
how it's a fucked up situation.
Are they really getting rid of doing that?
Well,
you know,
like when if you,
if you were to say any word,
people are like,
oh my God,
this person said this.
It's racist.
It's like I was just saying clan.
I wasn't saying anything else,
but it's like the Hitler mustache.
You just gotta let it go.
Too tricky is if anybody wants to wear the Hitler mustache now.
Like you can't really,
you can't.
Who wants to wear it?
Is there,
is somebody wearing it where for awhile?
That's right.
He did.
Oh my God,
he did playing basketball.
That's kind of fun.
If he was playing basketball thing,
he wasn't,
he was retired Hanes commercial or something I think.
Oh yeah,
he hit my God Damn Hitler.
You can
praise.
You can't even like when does it become a Charlie Chaplin?
It starts as a Hitler.
Like when it gets to the outer edge of the nostrils.
Is it a Charlie Chaplin?
Well Charlie Chaplin had a Hitler Hee Hee Ma.
He molded it after modeled after Hitler.
Yeah.
Hitler was a huge fan of Chaplin.
Absolutely.
There's,
there's some crossover there.
Chaplain was a huge fan of Hitler.
Hitler was a fan of chaplains and chaplain just kind of,
you know,
cause Chapman was a little bit of a rebel man.
So why the chaplain?
Whereas Mustache,
I think it's like a little tongue in cheek.
How Michael Jordan or mustache boosted sales and let me see that photo.
Wow.
Larger.
Okay.
That is so
crazy.
That is so crazy.
That is while you've been here,
give it up.
Even Michael motherfucking Jordan.
What is the second paragraph say Jordan camouflage is the mustaches to a small
extent with a corresponding soul patch under his bottom lip,
but the lip beard appears to be exactly that.
A beard tried to disguise the Teutonic neighbor upstairs.
Great sentence.
Yeah,
that's a great,
that's a great sentence to tonic neighbor to tonic neighbor.
That's really good to tonic means.
Do you know what to tonic means?
I've never used that word.
Capitalized it.
Hit it.
Maybe like a probably cause it's not a real word and motherfucker thinks it's a
domain of war or something like some,
okay.
Let's see.
It says relating to towns really into two tones,
denoting Germanic branch at the Indo European language family definition.
You're like,
what's the tonic?
So go back to that.
Go back to that statement again.
Back to the statement.
Oh,
they were just reading from,
yeah.
Okay.
Choose a beer to disguise.
It's two tonic neighbor upstairs.
How's that?
So maybe those people wore those stashes.
Maybe Hitler got it from those people's dramatic,
dramatic,
maybe it was a dramatic mustache.
Yeah,
maybe it was all a mode of the times.
Yeah.
I mean maybe a bunch of people at Hitler's kind of like how there's full beards
now.
This is like as a full beard.
The Hitler of our assistant.
Just like a common beard.
Can you imagine if somebody wrote what rolled around with a Hitler mustache
today?
That'd be really wild.
You can't,
you can't.
That's too much.
Right?
But here's what's weird,
and I've talked about this on stage too.
Why is it okay to dress like kingus Khan,
who's dressing like gang is con?
If you want to do it for Halloween,
why is it okay?
Yeah.
What do you mean?
Like it shouldn't be okay being a Nazi.
You can't be Hitler.
Yeah,
that's,
I mean,
that's just won't let you,
well,
it's also kind of lacking creativity.
Like you want to be a Hitler.
It's like dressing up like a sexy baby.
Are we really doing this?
Is this necessary?
No one needs to see sexy babies.
No one needs to see a Hitler.
Slow your roll.
Some girls should definitely dress like a sexy baby.
Girls can dress like sexy babies,
but I can't dress like a baby and open up packages on youtube.
You could dress like a baby and open up packages on youtube.
No one's stopping you.
I'm going to look funny doing visible foes cause you just said that it would be
Q and now before.
It wasn't when I wanted to do it.
I don't know what you're talking.